it's great to welcome will summer back
to the program will is a tech reporter
for the daily beast
also author of the wright richter
newsletter on conservative media
a great person to follow on twitter i
would also say will
uh thanks uh thanks for being back on
hey thanks for having me
so we've been we've been following and
talking about
uh q anon we've talked with media
matters alex kaplan
about q anon members who have a real
shot at being elected to congress so we
talked about marjorie taylor greene of
georgia colorado's
lauren beaubert there are others as well
okay
let's first start with with your
assessment of the strength of this as an
actual political movement
um yeah you know i i think humanon is
really getting a foothold within the gop
um we saw a poll this week that said
roughly 40 percent of
republican correspondent our respondents
said that q1 is a good thing
um you know we've seen other polls
suggesting maybe around seven percent of
people believe in it
so you know i mean these are not it's
not a majority by any means
but given how crazy their beliefs are
you know it's pretty concerning
is uh i read an interesting article by
greg stanton and we may be speaking to
him at some point in the future
where he points out that q anon
ideology to the extent that we can call
it an ideology
is really like rebranded anti-semitic
tropes that there's a lot of overlap
with
ideas from the protocols of the elders
of zion and just a lot of the standard
tropes of white nationalism and
anti-semitism that we've seen
do you agree and like what what portion
is
is made up of that yeah sure so q and on
it's sort of like scientology
where when people first get into it like
they don't tell you kind of the wildest
stuff
so you know people get in and they'll
say like you know don't you think
jeffrey epstein was bad obviously
obviously people do
and then they kind of get you in there
and then when you're really into it they
say
well really q anon is about people in
banking in hollywood which
obviously kind of code um drinking
children's blood
so you know i mean you get right into
blood libel right there so you know
this i you know q anon really is about
you know alleging all these powerful
jewish people are controlling the world
so um you know pretty anti-semitic on
its face
there has been uh that in the last 48
hours it seems
far less likely that this will happen
but donald trump had been banking
uh for political reasons on a vaccine
probably sometime in the next six weeks
uh which was likely to be an emergency
use authorization not a full approval
from the fda the idea being that he
could sort of attach himself to it and
take credit for it
at the same time their q anon
seems to be relatively anti-vaxx am i
wrong about that so so i'm
i'm seeing a very strange situation
where trump has previously tweeted about
vaccines and autism
he had to kind of be talked off a ledge
by ben carson during debates during the
2016 republican primary
now he's sort of all in on a vaccine and
yet
this group seems very anti-vaxx
yeah it's an interesting contradiction
um you know as you said trump has kind
of
promoted anti-vaccine stuff in the past
um but now
but in q anon people uh often are
varying anti-vaccine
um q or anti-vaccine facebook groups can
be
sort of a a gateway into q anon and so
we've seen especially during the
pandemic we've seen interest in q anon
explode
um along with a lot of skepticism about
vaccines
and now you have trump come out and say
well you know the vaccine is really key
to everything
and so i mean there definitely is a
clash there i mean q1 people have been
saying you know bill
gates is going to put a microchip in the
vaccine yeah
and suddenly trump kind of has to turn
these people around on it
when you look at um the
media foothold to the extent that it
exists for q anon
are they uh linked in any way
to any particular media outlets or
publications
and in particular i'm interested about
whether there's a connection with
oan this uh sort of like uh poor man's
fox news
kind of a blend between fox news and and
a porn parody of sorts
um that that donald trump has regularly
called on during his press briefings
yeah you know we see q a on its face is
so ridiculous
that even conservative media often wants
to distance themselves from it
but what they end up doing is sort of
taking ideas from q and on
and then sort of laundering them taking
stripping the q
on name off of it and running with it in
the case of oan initially they were very
anti-q anon
um but you know i just had a story this
week that they've been selling the use
of q anon emojis
on their youtube channel uh including
one referring to jfk jr coming back to
life
so you know i mean really there it seems
like they've just decided to start
profiting from it
right on the david pakman show youtube
channel if you subscribe
you get various colored show logos
and yet on oan you get q anon stuff
that's certainly a different approach i
guess to uh to sort of monetizing
content
yeah well maybe you should consider you
know an emoji that's like send hillary
to gitmo all this stuff
right i should i should look at look at
that direction so okay
let's zoom out a little bit because
you're following a lot of these
different movements
what else is there right now that maybe
our audience is not super familiar with
i mean i think my audience is very
familiar with you know kind of your
standard trumpus talking points we've
looked at video from rallies
god is protecting me from the virus or
the virus itself is a hoax sort of that
wing which is anything trump says they
they kind of repeat
we've got this q anon wing what other
sort of
subgroups are relevant in the underbelly
right now
yeah well you know i mean obviously
we've got these sort of violent groups
um like the proud boys
or uh the these various kind of militias
that i think are really starting to
merge with q anon in some ways
um and really this is you know
especially relevant as we head into
the election and these people are you
know there's all this kind of civil war
type rhetoric
um and you know i think maybe one of the
most interesting ones um
again with some ties to q and on is the
growth of these conspiracy theories
in like wellness and like yoga like
instagram influencers
i have not heard about this this is
interesting yeah so the typical q a
believer is you know white older kind of
evangelical
um but what we're seeing is there's this
group called save the children
and this is kind of a q anon front group
and they're having rallies with hundreds
of people across the world
in different cities and they're they're
sucking in a lot of
moms on facebook you know cue a mom uh
and you know these various instagram
yoga people who normally post about you
know
eating yogurt and doing yoga and all
this stuff and then they'll just be like
you know but but we got to get to the
bottom of what's going on at comet ping
pong
uh so you know it's disturbing stuff and
i think it suggests that these
conspiracy theories can go beyond just
the trump base
you mentioned the the demographics of
the typical q anon supporter
one of the things we learned about 2016
was that the rate of the dissemination
a re-sharing of fake news was
significantly skewed
not just to the right but to older folks
uh and we could talk about sort of the
the reasons why
q anon seems to have a significant
younger contingent that maybe wasn't
there with some of the
predominant fake news stories of 2016 is
my impression correct
that's absolutely right and you know one
example just to to pick one
is that q and on and tick tock or excuse
me and pizzagate
are exploding on tick tock with young
people and they'll make these tick tock
videos that say like you know here's
something about john podesta
you know and like yeah that now is there
anything that you can
uh ascertain as to why
this is getting more pickup with younger
folks whereas a lot of the 2016 stuff
did not is it just that
the technology now has changed in such a
way or the environment is different or
is it a concerted effort
you know i think it's i think maybe the
biggest part is that the world just
seems like it's gotten a lot crazier
um you know and you have these obviously
you have the very real epscene stuff
that i think pulls people into these
conspiracy theories
you know you have the pandemic and so i
think there's just a lot more people who
are kind of looking
to get a grasp on what's going on and
unfortunately they kind of fall down
these rabbit holes in
uh in 2010 we saw the rise of the tea
party movement
and a number of tea party candidates one
tea party caucus was created in the in
the house of representatives
uh and then eventually the tea party the
caucus still exists but
some of it kind of went away and some
elements were integrated into the
republican party but there was never
the tea party was not associated with a
presidential candidate
in the way that q anon is associated
with trump
so can you outline the likely paths
where you've got
so you have trump and then some q anon
candidates they
they all could win or they all might
lose or some combinations of the two
what's the sort of path forward look
like depending on what happens in
november
sure i mean here's what we're looking at
in terms of like how many q and on
people are going to be in congress next
year
right so we've got marjorie taylor green
in georgia who you mentioned um you know
she's in a really republican district
she's a republican
so she's almost certain to win um you
know trump's endorsed her
the i think it's very interesting that
the the white house has been very
real they just will not criticize q anon
which i think
is another sign of cuban on power um you
know and in fact when a republican
lawmaker came out and did criticize q
and on the trump campaign attacked him
so you know that's kind of the line is
like don't talk about q anon
and certainly not in a negative way um
we've got lauren bobert in colorado
house candidate kind of a battleground
district she says well i don't believe
in q and on anymore
oh well great you know i mean you know
she said you know i support q and on i
hope it's real and now she's kind of
backed away
um but so she's maybe got a toss-up
chance um
you know in i believe oregon and
uh and delaware that there are
republican senate nominees who have
believed in queued on um they're
probably not going to win
um but still you know out of 35 senate
races we've got two
two uh with q and on believers so you
know
i think the gop is really failing to
stand up to this and so i i think we can
expect to see more of it
to what degree should the democratic
party
engage with this criticize it and and uh
what i mean it you know there's often a
discussion about
uh platforming versus ignoring versus
responsible platforming as some call it
do you have a sense of
whether this has risen to a point at
which we need to hear more from the left
about it
well you know it's really hard to say i
mean as you say on one
hand you don't want maybe joe biden
going out every day and saying
uh you know here's what key went on is
you know because you're exposing a
certain amount of people to it
on the other hand i think certainly when
it comes to the media um you know
the the cow has left the barn i think in
terms of
not telling people that q and or hoping
it doesn't get bigger um you know we're
talking about q and on murders q and on
terrorism q and on kidnapping
and you know at some point i do think
you know we have to trust voters and the
audience
uh to know what's going on even you know
even
if it's very crazy if you look around
the uh
if you look around the country and you
see some of the different
groups that i mean my take well maybe
let's let's actually start there to see
if we're on the same page on this piece
my take generally has been that donald
trump has not
really generated new racism or
xenophobia or radicalism
but has made that which already existed
sort of more comfortable being public
about it
question one is do you agree with that
assessment or has has trump's presidency
actually created more of that well you
know
certainly i think uh you know i wouldn't
want to suggest that trump is
you know kind of a unique character in
terms of uh you know racism
uh on the other hand i think in terms of
conspiracy theories i think having a guy
in the white house
who promotes this stuff obviously was a
big birther and legitimizes it
i do think that kind of brings the gop
it basically provides an opening i think
for these conspiracy theories
to take over the gop and get more people
from within
so so i guess the question is if trump
loses are we to expect that a lot of
these
groups whose views are now much more in
the open
are they going to go back underground in
some sense it doesn't eliminate the
views it doesn't
de-radicalize but it would be again an
environment where they are less
comfortable being public about their
views or is the cats sort of out of the
bag
at this point you know it's hard to
really predict what happens
um but but i do think that potentially
if trump loses you know some people are
anticipating you know it's like the
spell lifts the q and on people don't
believe in it anymore
i think instead what's going gonna
happen is that these people who have
been so revved up
and basically convinced that democrats
are like you know eating children and
they're satanists and all this
and that trump's gonna solve it and then
when he loses they're gonna say
well the deep state did it uh now we
have to take matters into our own hands
so you know i i feel like i could see
really q on sort of being integrated
more into the gop potentially in a
violent way
one other thing i specifically on the q
anon beliefs i wanted to ask about
a lot of the as you say sometimes the
the gateway to q anon is
jeffrey epstein related the more we know
about epstein the more sort of touch
points there are with donald trump and
there are even allegations that were
made in a lawsuit which have said
the lawsuit has since been been pulled
but they were allegations about
joint sexual assault involving donald
trump and jeffrey epstein
is there no concern in your mind or
discussion among q anon
that the more they push this that it
could actually implicate donald trump
no i mean you know they have so much
like cognitive dissonance and
rationalization
uh when it comes to trump i mean
obviously trump you know appointed the
prosecutor who gave epstein a sweetheart
deal to the cabinet
um you know obviously there's videos of
trump and epstein hanging out and kind
of appraising women together yeah
um and so instead what they say is that
you know trump was
infiltrating epstein's circle and that
by
uh by appointing this prosecutor to the
cabinet he was kind of
drawing more attention to this dirty
deal and all this kind of stuff
that that's like a textbook example of
the unfalsifiable argument it's
you know there's an invisible tiger in
this room oh all right well
let's you know uh let's let's lay down
some baby powder so as the invisible
tiger walks around it'll disturb the
baby powder
well no it's also a weightless invisible
tiger like there's no
you cannot possibly uh disabuse someone
of those beliefs and that
maybe that's part maybe that's by design
i guess
absolutely i mean part of the beauty of
the q am clues the genius of it
is that even when they make predictions
people will say you know the prediction
doesn't come true they'll say
well maybe we just misread the
predictions we were wrong um or that
some maybe q was trying to throw off the
deep state you know with some bad info
um and so really this makes it really
hard to disabuse people of these notions
um and you know i hear all the time from
people
who have lost family members or loved
ones uh to q and on and
you know it's really hard to get people
out of it we've been speaking with will
summer
tech reporter for the daily beast also
author of the wright richter newsletter
on conservative media
will always great speaking with you
absolutely thanks for having me